dear Sarah read your question thank you
very much for submitting it I am I think
that despite the political differences
and the challenges that Muslims and the
United States face in their relationship
there are several areas of common ground
that they can work on together and what
that requires is a robust network of
civil society partnerships it can't just
be government-to-government bridges
between governments can be very fragile
but networks between populations between
communities are much more robust and can
withstand the challenge of political
conflicts and even violent conflict so i
would encourage business people and
media and those who head ngos all
different sectors from each society to
find areas that they can work on
together it's only going to be through
building those robust networks that the
two groups can
withstand the challenges to their
relationship
ok